you're going to perform the song Mad
Man's eyes this is off the new album yes
um mad Man's eyes is your statement
about the gun violence going on it
seemed like a common statement like the
fear of losing people to gun violence is
always there you know and there's no
safe place
you know from it you had all these
thoughts about gun violence and what did
you have a tune in mind I mean because
it's a tough subject to write about it
yeah so that's why I wasn't meaning I it
wasn't my it wasn't my goal so I'd been
messing around with this lick that I
liked a lot the lick was this
[Music]
yeah so that's and I played that for
ages what do you mean over and over and
over again just keep playing it and like
would your wife say to you what the [__]
are you doing David yeah she also says I
love it when you play guitar like this
she does because
and then I found these other parts
[Music]
so you have that yeah but there's no
tune like there's no lyrics There's no
gun violence thoughts it's just it's
just I've got this and I was messing
with it for a while you know and and so
I found a few I'll play the song Can I
play the song play the song yeah
[Music]
little Billy's got a gun Little Bill is
having fun
[Music]
shooting bottles on the wall dreams the
hero come home from work
[Music]
is this real is this make believe
I think we know how everything's
supposed to be but like a train blowing
full steam ahead I can't hear what
you're saying Well everybody's screaming
I'm afraid can't lie mama said baby
don't you cry in the dark be the light
don't let go Baby Hold On Tight to
believe it's blind don't sacrifice
another child it's not black and white
unless we're looking through a madman's
eyes
again
[Music]
it might not be crystal clear but if
might is right there's no room for love
in here
[Music]
pray to God your hope is listening a man
with a gun brings the demons in
[Music]
but we live as if I were ahead
is it really so hard to do what we know
is right and to protect some foolish
things we hold dear must we do things
that we should never
forgive I'm afraid can't lie mama said
baby don't you cry in the dark be the
light don't let go Baby Hold On Tight to
believe it's blind don't sacrifice
another child it's not black and white
unless you're looking through a madman's
eyes
[Music]
don't ask why nobody wants to see the
look in his eyes
[Music]
when it's too late to untwist the knife
how do we face hatred with love inside
us I'm afraid can't lie mama said baby
don't you cry in the dawn be the light
don't let go Baby Hold On Tight to
believe it's blind don't sacrifice
another child it's not black and white
yes you're looking through a madman's
eyes
foreign